ces comédiens ne pouvait bel et bien pas
fumer sur scène même si la cigarette
faisait partie de la mise en scène la
cour du québec confirme l'interdiction à
laquelle s'objecte 3 théâtre de québec
tinqueux la cigarette doit exister dans
la vie et que notre métier est de
représenter la réalité il faut trouver
une façon de pouvoir fumer sur scène
entre 2017 et 2019 les théâtre de la
bordée du trident et premier acte ont
tour à tour été mise à l'amendé pour
avoir fait fumer des acteurs sur scène
sanctions qu'ils ont contesté se disant
même prêt à faire des compromis on se
dit mais peut-être qu'il peut avoir
quelque chose qui pouvait bien ménager
la chèvre et le chou c'est un
avertissement disons quand on achète un
billet quelque chose dans sa décision le
juge yannick couture conclu le débat
porte sur la façon de représenter l'acte
de fumer par les acteurs lors d'une
expression théâtrale et ou artistique
plutôt que sur la légitimité de l'action
de jouer une personne qui fume et il n'y
a en soi aucune atteinte de la liberté
d'expression artistique il ajoute que la
loi et ses règlements n'empêche pas un
comédien de simuler le geste de fumée
sur scène de différentes façons en
utilisant divers accessoires artifice ou
quelques effets spéciaux faut que ce
soit réaliste si on fait semblant les
spectateurs décroche et on l'avait bien
expliqué aux juges d'un choix fait par
un metteur en scène par un auteur en
fait quand il écrit un rôle où l'acteur
va fumer se soient pas considérés comme
étant un acte expressif voilà je suis
passablement étonné les compagnies
estime aussi que cette décision dépasse
les murs des théâtres on parle aussi des
plateaux des plateaux de cinéma du
studio tellis quelqu'un se plaint c'est
le même jugement par tous les
gestionnaires des trois théâtres doivent
se rencontrer demain pour discuter de la
suite des choses ils ont maintenant un
mois pour déterminer s'ils vont porter
leur cause en appel ici cassandra nadeau
la marche radio canada québec